boy goes out with his father to
breakfast he goes and he says uh I want
to start football and the father says I
don't think so he's like why not he's
like I think you're just interested I
don't think you're you're really
committed to doing he's like no I'm
committed and so he's looking at the
kid's plate and the waiter comes by and
serves it and he's got ham and he's got
eggs on the plate he says you know the
difference between the eggs and the ham
here what well the chicken was
interested right it had eggs the pig
he's committed right and so right now I
feel like you're interested do you think
interested people are the on who lose
weight everybody's interested in looking
better are you interested or you
committed